so I say ch4 is the only movie that
comes out this weekend in wide release I
don't know why I say ch4 is the latest
Ice Age movie you know we got these
prehistoric creatures and it's a
children's family adventure kind of
thing where they're in the wild one of
the things a series is trying to do is
it tries to incorporate times in history
in which things happen to change the
earth you got Ray Romano as this mammoth
Queen Latifah as the wife Denis Leary as
the saber-tooth John Leguizamo's there
and then my favorite character is
scrapped a little squirrel those are
always my favorite parts of these movies
whenever they show the little squirrel
trying to get the Acorn or whatever his
little adventures favorite character in
the whole movie this movie does it shows
how the tectonic plates started shifting
and then the continents started drifting
into various places and how that affects
their family they're trying to get back
together because they got drifted apart
I'm not really a big fan of the Ice Age
films it's like there are certain
animated films that are more for
families and then something a more for
kids like say the Happy Feet movies this
movie is more for the kids I will say
though that it's not like a movie that
you're gonna go and you're just gonna
sit there and be like oh that's just so
horrible I just can't stand my life
right now it's like what I'm watching
this am i okay I don't mind washing this
the music is really good the CGI is nice
but I really don't give a crap about
anything they're saying at all and I was
kind of thinking there really aren't
that many of these children's animated
features that have made it all the way
to a fourth installment just really
Shrek and most people think that after
the second film they kind of sucked
after that the thing is these movies
make money they make a ton of money they
make their budget back and more so so
they're going to make Ice Age movies
until that ends because these movies
make money and that's why they keep
having this really should be called Ice
Age for continental cash grab now a
friend of mine he brought his two
daughters all right and he fell asleep
and he rarely ever falls asleep during
movies his kids however loved it that is
like the perfect thing that I could
possibly use to explain this movie
now there's two character in this movie
I like I really like Denis Leary as the
sabre-tooth I just like him for some
reason I think he's a good with the
voice acting he actually feels like in
some way he was actually contributing
something everyone else just seems like
they were there because basically all
these factors have to do is stand in a
sound booth and read some lines and they
get like a million dollar
I think was Chris Rock recently and
especially was talking about Madagascar
3 and he was like yeah I just basically
sit there and read lines and you get
like a million dollars that's exactly
what he said that's just that step blows
my mind really but I like the
sabre-tooth character you know and then
I like scrap the squirrel his his scenes
of the best parts the whole movie when
he's hunting for these acorns of course
you have already seen two entire scenes
that Scrat has in the trailers for this
movie there's a reason they used those
scenes to market these movies they're
the best scenes in the movie one of the
things I did like about this movie
though was the villainous character this
this monkey guy I thought he was pretty
cool he was actually neat villain even
though he got introduced with a song
which is like the most cliched thing you
can possibly do to introduce a cartoon
villain is have him sing some big evil
song I kind of like this character he
was funny he was an interesting villain
this movie has some good action
sequences is actually some really cool
action in the score by John Powell I
could see that in like any type of movie
besides this actually being a really
good action score he did the born scores
you know he's a good composer this movie
has this really really corny subplot
where the young mammoth thinks the other
young mammoth is such a hot stud and she
has to impress him uh see when the
little mammoth people look at a giant
avalanche of some kind and they say epic
this is that kind of movie all right
it's a family movie but it's it's a kids
movie this is strictly a kids movie I
really don't recommend seeing Ice Age
it's just it's it's kind of boring it
really isn't that good I'm going to give
I say just see there's no reason for
these movies to continue except for the
fact that they make a ton of money and
kids love them so if you're basically a
teenager or above I would stay away from
my stage four and as always guys if you
like this review you can subscribe to my
channel and get stuck mine eyes